in Austin Texas living in a van an
eternal open micro and we changed his
life he sells out all around the world
including this weekend in New York City
a sold out Sony Hall ladies and
gentlemen sing it if you know the words
this is Hans Kim
hey
what's up guys good to be here
um I have a beautiful girlfriend as a
lot of you know my girlfriend is great
she uh makes me have sex with her after
I've already come
which is fine but she keeps expecting
first deck activities on the third dick
like I've already come twice she's
shoving it in sideways
bouncing on it
I feel like a pool noodle on a slip and
slide
I'm not going anywhere
I think in women's sports all the refs
should be women because men aren't going
to be able to catch the fouls that women
do
oh foul you're being petty
[Laughter]
you only did that to her because she did
that to you earlier
I uh I'm sad to hear that Trump is
getting indicted again I think Biden
indicts Trump every time he falls over
all right thank you all right Hans Kim
beautiful minute
a lot of punches not exactly hard
punches but a lot of TAPS the whole way
through a lot like Nate Diaz versus Jake
Paul you landed a lot of punches didn't
do a ton of damage but Rock Solid set
you did it again that's how you do it
you're a real surgeon
um my parents wish I was a surgeon uh
yes they do I love that description on
my set it's a lot like the description
of my love life a lot of soft taps
so let's talk about it you say that
you're having a lot of sex after you
come that's her choice or your choice
it's her choice explain to us uh what
time what does she say to you like what
goes on which is like you want to
vibrate me
what does that mean
uh the vibrator the Hitachi comes out oh
yeah the real Asian Workhorse in the
household
oh yeah
and then she's like wouldn't it be
better if your dick was inside me and
then oh yeah I guess so
is there something she can do that
magically gets you hard are there any
tricks to getting Huns Kim hard is there
any way to turn your lo mein noodle into
a [__]
into a uh a girl yes thank you
thank you thank you for helping me be
racist there a little teamwork goes a
long way
um her go-to move is just squeezing my
dick with her butt she uh squeezing your
dick with her butt man I've been doing
it wrong this whole time
I've never even heard of that
she just backs it right up into it she
uh she doesn't give me any breathing
room down there look at that the Old
South Korea
unbelievable so she just pushes her butt
back and then squeezes her butt cheeks
and you're just like oh
and you get hard yeah wow how many what
do you think the most times that you've
had sex in a 24-hour period with your
girlfriend is probably four oh okay
that's good all right oh 24 hour
probably yeah six oh okay all right in
honor of Bob Barker we're changing
numbers here
the late great Bob Barker which is also
the name of a dog that Hans his parents
ate uh okay all right
you said that your parents wish you were
a surgeon if you talked to your parents
lately what are they saying about your
current life they're like oh you have a
Rolex oh that's like a doctor
um you know
again all the good parts of being a
doctor the private jets and none of the
uh blood and you know anuses well it
sounds like you do get some means yeah
sounds like the only thing that can make
you hard
uh consensually
um no one questioned whether it was
consensual it's a real weird disclaimer
to throw out yeah now we're thinking it
wasn't yeah
now it's kind of rapey he does have that
did find out last week that you do play
a game with your girlfriend called rape
yes have you guys played this week yes
uh-huh did you win or did she win I I
won this time I want to know one one and
one one and one yes
absolutely this video will be used in a
court of law at some point
amazing all right Hans what else is
going on this week fresh off a Sony Hall
sold out New York City it was an amazing
time I lived in New York for three years
you know a lot of my most toxic
personality traits are from that city
um I I headlined Sony Hall it was a
dream come true must be amazing to go
back to New York and headline we know
for a fact that uh you slept in your van
there in New York City before moving
here to Austin Texas and when you were
in New York the big [__] Apple you
could not sell a single ticket no one
knew who what a Hans Kim was right yeah
nobody likes me well no one knew you so
I knew him and I didn't like them I have
to say
what do you remember about Hans in the
New York scene I don't I always think I
saw him like an open mic once I think he
didn't really cross a whole lot of paths
that's where I lived yeah
um outside of the creek in the cave in
New York correct yes I was a hobo
um I stayed in an Airbnb this week that
cost more than you know my van did yeah
um it's pretty great you know it's
played Sony Hall which was a dream of
mine ever since I found out it existed
four months ago
absolutely
one day I started Sony Hall you'll work
your way up to Hitachi Hall and uh
really shake the [__] crowd you know
what I mean okay Hans well fun times you
did it again you got the show started I
don't think you should be challenged
next week so you get another week off
way to do it Hans can everybody
that was Hans Kim that was Hans Kim that
was Hans Kim that was Hans Kim all right
pulling another